THE DOT AT DAN BONGINO NEWS
EXPLOSION.
OUR FAVORITE NEW YORK CITY COP
AND SECRET SERVICE AGENT IS HERE
TO GIVE US THE TOP THREE NEWS
STORIES OF THE PAST SEVEN DAYS.
THE GREAT DAN BONGINO JOINS US
TONIGHT.
>> Dan: I HAVE FOUR.
IT WILL BE A NICE UFO SEGMENT.
APPARENTLY SOME UNITED STATES
SENATORS HAVE RECEIVED AN ACTUAL
BRIEFING ON THE USO PHENOMENON.
NOW LIKE YOU, I ALWAYS WONDER
WHY THIS ISN'T A BIGGER STORY.
TUCKER, WE DON'T HAVE TO GO ALL
HD WELLS WERE OF THE WORLD,
THERE IS NO NEED FOR DRAMA.
BUT IF YOU HAD SOME STUFF FLYING
OVER YOUR COUNTRY WITH THE
TECHNOLOGY NO ONE COULD EXPLAIN,
MAYBE IT'S KIND OF A BIGGER
DEAL, RIGHT?
MAYBE WE SHOULD BE A LITTLE MORE
CONCERNED.
JUST THROWING THAT OUT THERE FOR
THE AUDIENCE.
>> Tucker: THAT'S A FAIR
CONCERN, I WOULD SAY.
AND THE IRANIANS A VERY SERIOUS
STORY HITTING ONE OF OUR DRONES.
A $100 MILLION PLUS DRONE.
TUCKER, YOU AND I DON'T AGREE ON
EVERYTHING IN POLITICS BUT I
HAVE TO TELL YOU, I HAVE TOLD
YOU THIS FROM THE START.
AND IT'S VERY EASY TO MAKE THESE
DECISIONS ABOUT HUMAN LIVES WHEN
IT'S NOT YOUR ON THE LINE.
THE WAY SOME OF THESE PEOPLE
HAVE CASUALLY THROWN AROUND MORE
LIKE IT'S A TRIP TO
McDONALD'S, IT'S CANDIDLY OF
EMBARRASSING FOR PEOPLE WITH
SUCH HIGH IQs.
>> THAT'S A BETTER DESCRIPTION.
>> YES HE DID.
SO STORY NUMBER TWO, TRUMP 2020
BEGINS.
LISTEN, I AM A SUPPORTER OF THE
PRESIDENT AND A CONSERVATIVE ON
A LOT OF HIS CONSERVATIVE
ISSUES.
I'M NOT A NEWS GUY, I'M AN
OPINION GUY AND I DON'T THINK
THAT'S A SECRET.
BUT TUCKER, ENERGY MATTERS AND
THIS RALLY IN ORLANDO WAS A
MONSTER AND I MEAN THAT IN A
GOOD WAY.
I RAN FOR OFFICE.
IT'S 94 DEGREES HERE ON
CHRISTMAS.
IT'S A GREAT ESTATE IN THE UNION
AND I LOVE IT BUT YOU WAKE UP
CHRISTMAS MORNING AND YOU COULD
ROAST MARSHMALLOWS ON THE
SIDEWALK.
YOU HAD 20,000 PEOPLE SITTING IN
ORLANDO IN THE POURING RAIN IN
90 DEGREES, WAITING TO SEE THIS
GUY.
THE PRESIDENT CLEARLY TAPPED
INTO SOMETHING HERE THAT THE
AMERICAN PUBLIC NEEDS AND WANTS.
HONESTLY TUCKER, THE ENERGY
HASN'T WANED ONE BIT.
HE PACKED THAT ENTIRE STADIUM.
ONE QUICK THING, CROWDS ARE NOT
NECESSARILY DISPOSITIVE.
I DON'T WANT TO GET HYPERBOLIC
ON EITHER END BUT THE DEMOCRATS
IGNORING THIS PHENOMENA AND
AGAIN WILL BE EGG ON THE FACE
TWICE IF THEY UNDERESTIMATE THIS
MAN'S CAPACITY TO WIN AN
ELECTION.
BIG MISTAKE.
HUGE.
TO QUOTE JULIA ROBERTS FROM
PRETTY
"PETTY
"PRETY
"PRETTY WOMAN."
NEVER LAUGH AT YOUR OWN JOKES BY
THE WAY.
THREE NUMBER ONE IS THE BIDEN
BOOMERANG.
IF YOU ARE GOING TO USE IDENTITY
POLITICS, REMEMBER TUCKER,
JOE BIDEN, MITT ROMNEY WAS GOING
TO PUT YOU BACK IN CHAINS.
IF THIS WILL BE OUR ENTIRE
POLITICAL STRATEGY, AND IT'S
ONLY A MATTER OF TIME BEFORE
BOOMERANG IS IN YOUR FACE AND IT
HAPPENED THIS WEEK WITH SLOPPY
JOE, WHERE OF COURSE HE MADE A
COMMENT ABOUT WORKING WITH
SEGREGATIONISTS AND HE GAVE AN
OPENING TO PEOPLE LIKE BOOKER
AND OTHERWISE WHO DON'T REALLY